kaylynn brings the tea I mean things get
about as bad as they can Demi's into
guys and girls I'm fluid I like and John
Paul Jones makes an entrance I'm finally
meeting John Paul Jones and apparently
being John Paul Jones friend as well
bachelor in paradise kicked off its
sixth season Monday night we saw plenty
of familiar faces hit the beach
including Kahlan and Demi from Colton's
season of The Bachelor and fan fave John
Paul Jones from Hannah Browns season of
The Bachelorette
[Applause]
[Music]
but amid the budding romances of Hanna
GE and Dylan and Demi and Derek spoiler
they made out the drama has popped off
now
let's unpack that was awkward
Kahlan and Blake apparently have a
romantic history and dated prior to
coming on the show but he allegedly told
Kaelyn he wanted to keep that info a
secret he calls me like two weeks ago
and is like no one can know about it
we've gotta live we gotta lie our asses
off in paradise reason why he wanted to
keep their relationship hush-hush
well it seems he was also dating
Christina yes Christina from Nick vile
season who used to date Dean from
Rachael Lindsay's season we have to
update to the day before I hooked up
with you I hooked up with Christina
the ladies of paradise were fawning over
Blake during night one which didn't sit
well with the former pageant princess
and he ended up getting the first date
card of the season which he used to Wine
and Dine Taoiseach Adams
et caught up with tisha on premiere
night at ABC's TCA event in Los Angeles
where she revealed bachelor nation
should buckle up and more dramas about
to come out and it's gonna start
involving more people than just myself a
lot more Blake a lot more Blake that's
definitely true especially since
Christina showed up the day after tshis
date with Blake and asked him out this
was going to be a fun date so how bad do
things get for him is there any
redemption for Blake he made the initial
mistake it's bad it's just there's
nothing good about it
the initial mistake being the stagecoach
the disaster that was stagecoach where
he was with Christina the next night was
with Kaylin not a good look not a great
move not smart at all thinking he was
somehow going to get away with that and
just stroll into paradise and he was
gonna be just this great time he would
move on that is what is beyond me that's
what I don't understand what was he
thinking was going to happen if the
teaser for the rest of season six has
shown us anything it's that we're in for
a bumpy boat ride through paradise
[Music]
[Applause]